conga Skylanders poked with eye candy
and giant monster fights but director
Jordan vogt-roberts also stuffed a movie
full of pop-culture Easter eggs
referencing everything from anime to
Jurassic Park all dhaniya birds and
congas especially for the video game
Easter eggs here all the ones you missed
in Kong Skull Island Metal Gear Solid
Jordan vogt-roberts is a massive Metal
Gear Solid fan
he told den of geek that's one of the
most important franchises to me on the
planet not even just as a video game but
as a piece of media so it's no surprise
that the director couldn't help but put
a little bit of metal gear into Skull
Island
remember the name of the ramshackle boat
that Jhansi Riley's character builds
called the grey fox if that sounds
familiar to you you've probably played a
lot of video games gray fox is a
recurring character in the Metal Gear
franchise and according to vote roberts
the grey fox was only supposed to be the
tip of the iceberg when it came to
Skylands Metal Gear Solid references
screen rights at Dan Gilroy wrote a
sequence in which Tom Hiddleston's
character breaks into a military base
and devote Roberts claims he was going
to get very metal gear with it before
the scene was cut The Legend of Zelda
samuel l.jackson is group of pilots the
sky devils gets a lot of screen time
throughout kong that gives viewers
plenty of time to study their uniforms
and Zelda fans may have noticed that the
sky Devils insignia looks a lot like the
Hyrule winged crest which made his first
appearance in The Legend of Zelda the
ocarina of time my favorite game of all
time fYI on the resemblance isn't exact
but according to vote Roberts the
similarity is 100% intentional Pokemon
Skull Island scariest creatures aren't
giant Apes or bamboo spiders they're
those freaky two-legged reptiles Kiwis
won't speak their name but I can't skull
crawlers why because it sounds neat but
despite their ferociousness the skull
crawlers have a fairly curly origin
according to a behind-the-scenes feature
at Wired vogt-roberts caves a special
effects team a single reference to get
them started
cubone one of the very first Pokemon is
the kind of thing that's impossible to
unsee both creatures have long heads
that look like skulls and lizard like
bodies of course there's one big
difference but
the to the skull crawlers just look like
they're wearing another creature skull
cubone actually is the skull belongs to
his mother which is much more terrifying
Megaman and Metroid The Legend of Zelda
isn't the only big video game franchise
that snuck into the costumes of Kong
Skull Island
some of the helmet stunned by the pilots
in the movie resemble those worn by the
heroes in Megaman Metroid and the
classic Gundam franchise of course
summer some measurements bought helmet
of blocky extra parts the flight helmets
and scale Island are a lot more
realistic you have to study the designs
closely to see the similarities 3d
extrusions like the cups around Mega
Man's ears have been reduced to 2d paint
jobs and the color schemes are totally
different still if you look hard enough
to your notice on many of Megaman and
summerses iconic silhouettes reappear on
the helmets that's enough for us to
counter even if the gig sinners wish
that the similarities were just a little
more pronounced Resident Evil Kong Skull
Island introduced King Kong with a
stunning 360-degree shot that zooms
through several helicopter cockpits
while circling the giant ape it's an
exciting way to highlight scale Islands
biggest star and in the context of the
movie it goes a long way towards showing
just how big concrete is well guess what
vogt-roberts
totally stole the shot from a video game
he's not shy about to either he said
that's a very video game shot to me that
shot was actually inspired by a
cinematic in a Resident Evil game
vogt-roberts doesn't identify which
Resident Evil he's ripping off there are
a lot of games out there and almost as
many helicopter crashes in them but fans
think he's probably talking about
operation Raccoon City a non canon
third-person shooter Shadow of the
Colossus if you're making a movie about
giant monsters it makes sense that you
look to the most famous video game about
giant monsters for inspiration that's
exactly what vogt-roberts did he told a
den of geek Shadow of the Colossus was a
huge influence on me on this movie the
colossi in those games have such a slow
of melancholy morose quality to them and
the sense of scale I think and I hope
that Kong has a similar vibe in the film
in other words if you go into Kong Skull
Island looking for visuals borrowed from
Shadow of the Colossus you won't find
them if you think of Kong as a spiritual
descendant of the titular colossi
however your spots Shadow of the
Colossus is influenced throughout the
film like shadows colossi Kong is a
majestic and tragic figure
it's no surprise that they go hand in
hand journey in journey your player has
to cross a vast desert trying to reach a
glowing mountain in the distance you can
connect with other players but you can
only communicate with actions or musical
notes it's a stranger theory or gain
that's been called a kind of
nondenominational religious experience
for players Kong director Jordan
vogt-roberts review isn't quite so wordy
but gives a game just as much praise
journey is one of my favorite things
ever
as such vogt-roberts nuk journeys
illuminated mountain into skull island's
landscape the peaks are a little more
jagged in Kong but the silhouette is
unmistakable thanks for watching click
the loop icon to subscribe to our
youtube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you're loved too
[Music]